people say y'all USC's @ug even that
what I mean I've already done that I
know I know I felt what it feel like the
canvas feels I'm on the tolls and I've
been there in the marinas and stuff so
for me now it's just my own personal
journey this is what I'm doing and it
doesn't matter if I'm fighting in the
UFC KFC and my back garden I'll still
being chumps come every Monday every
Friday and I'll still be changing every
day of my life cuz it's what I love to
do
[Music]
I'm from the Hollifield
England born and bred a Wis where were
training right now we're in chaps camp
infamous and famous
what will pool world champions if you
look around the gym pictures all around
they're champions and you know I'd love
to get myself on this wall one day a bit
of an infamous area everybody knows my
side for the field you know when you
mention Manchester though you're not
from the area did lose a few friends
along the way to presume guns and things
like that what you know so does everyone
I mean it's quite a life and then this
MMA really saved a lot of the guys that
I teach now I'm myself on the path that
were on and turn me into a great person
disciplined and put me on the straight
and narrow path
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ya know like crossing the border into
Paulo field this sort of role there and
is one of my fighters now let's see what
he's doing
come and join the documentary mate was
she called Bella brothers famous and ago
in the field are not shown where he
original Jim was on there yeah oh yeah I
see on there being a dog running up it
was you expecting a pit then you all
where were you not like I've been round
this area all my life I'm 49 for 40
years 41 years so he's changed a lot
yeah
I won't say for good or bad chick shoes
off lads before you can live in it yeah
this is reception interception so we
used to be in here we've moved from all
yeah this was the ring this is the Kate
Hey people used to say the facade was
yeah oh what you in the park again why
yeah why where are you
doesn't my off because when you're in
the cage it's still the same place you
still gotta fight me doesn't matter if
you're in your big expensive gym do this
again in ten years you still see us
stood in this circle yeah maybe a bit
slower no that's what's up this is where
I develop my skill set you know I've
been training around here for ten years
and I want to put mine Chester martial
arts on the muck and I don't want to be
that guy that gets to a certain level
disappears from England and then like
Michael Brisbane and you hear of him ten
years later like I love England
well you've not lived there you've not
trained there you know you've been out
there and do you think I go out there
for six weeks training [ __ ] combat
whatever but this is where I'm born and
bred and this is the my life that I want
to put on the map on
just thrown them up on the one my sister
to get beyond me and I'll take it all
the way with it I'm not in it for the
fame the fortune and all right yeah I
love what I do
and I mean that from the bottom of my
heart I'm passionate and even if I was
fighting in this gym for the rest of my
life I wouldn't care this is this is
what I love to do what when I fought for
that world's Idol it was all about me me
me me me and then afterwards when I had
that decision is tough and some of the
messages I was getting from from people
around the area in the community I
realized that they say trust me no more
it's a much bigger thing and there's a
lot of people that I inspire and bring
along the way with me and stuff so for
now it's not just me it's about the area
and it's about everyone it's about
mccolts you know from this dream that we
started out with 10 years ago to keep
pushing it all the way and see how far
we can take it and I will not stop until
I get there